แนทุกมาแล้วครูเอ๋สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะน้อง
ต้อมเอ้ยครู
ต้อมสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียน
ทุกคนนะคะค่านะคะอ้าเดี๋ยวครูเอกขอแชร์
สกรีนนะคะครูต้อมมาค่ะครูเอ๋ววันนี้จะคุย
กันเรื่องอะไรดีนะมามยเห็นมยอุ๊บโอมีเยอะ
ยังไม่มาโอเคมาแล้วค่ะอู้หูอืูเอ๋อะไรอ่ะ
อะไรเหรออ๋อแวบๆแว๊บๆใช่มยแว๊บ
ๆวันนี้วันนี้ครูเอ๋กับครูต้อมคุยกันวัน
ไหนเนี่ยวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะครูเอ๋วัน
อาทิตย์ใช่มั้ยคะอ่ะเขียนวันหน่อยเนาะ
อุ๊บ
ค่ะวันอาทิตย์ครูต้อมเห็นมยเห็นแล้ว
ค่ะวันอาทิตย์ที่ 10 วันที่ 10 นะคะค่า
เดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กรกฎาคมปีค.ศอะไร 2
2022 ค่ะค.ศเออใช่ๆ
ๆปีค.ศพ.ศอะไรคะพ.ศ
2565 อ่า
2565 อือฮึแล้วตอนนี้ครูเดี๋ยวเลื่อน
กล้องก่อนนะคะครูต้อมออๆโอเคจะได้เห็น
หน้าครูต้อมด้วยไม่งั้นครูเอกอหันมาอ่า
แล้วเ่อครูต้อมคะตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงนะตอน
นี้เวลา 21:00 น
21  17 นค่ะ 2117 นเราก็จะพูดกันจนถึง 21
น 20  37  47 เนาะโอเคนะคะ 47 นาทีครูเอก
พูดเนาะเๆบ่อยๆนักเรียนเดี๋ยวนักเรียนจะ
เนาะไปด้วยเนาะเาๆเนๆเนๆๆๆคือใช่มยก็
เหมือนใช่มยแต่ว่าเวลาคุยกับเพื่อนก็เนาะ
อันนี้มันน่าอร่อยเราไม่พูดน่าอร่อยใช่มย
เราก็บอกน่าอร่อยเนาะอือือ่าเราจะพูดกัน
จนถึง 2147 ใช่มั้ยคะเออ
ฮะเออฮึก็ใช่ค่ะใช่ค่ะบางทีเราก็ไม่พูด
ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะแต่เราก็จะมีคำคำอื่นๆที่
ความหมายเหมือนกันนะคะอืเพราะว่านคำว่า
เนาะบ่อยๆก็ต้องค่ะอ่ะลบก่อนนะคะลบ
อ่าวันนี้ครูเอ๋จะคุยเรื่องอะไรคะเรื่อง
ไทยๆเพราะว่านักเรียนเรื่องไทยๆนักเรียน
เรียนภาษาไทยก็อยากรู้เกี่ยวกับคนไทย
โอ้ก็มีเรื่องนึงที่คนไทยเค้าจะทำต้องบอก
ว่าคนไทยเค้าจะทำกันนะคะค่ะแต่ว่าเอ๋บ้าน
เอ๋น่ะไทยจีนก็ไม่ได้ทำบ่อยๆก็ทำครั้ง
เดียวนะคะแต่ถ้าเป็นคนไทยจริงๆ
หรือคนไทยยไทยแบบไม่ใช่เป็นไทยจีนแบบครู
เออ๋อ่ะอืคือ 1 ปี 1 ปี 1 ครั้งอื 1 ปี
น่ะจะทำอันประเพณีเนี่ยเราเรียกเป็น
ประเพณีเลยนะคะเรียกว่างานบุญนะงานบุญก็
คืองานดีๆนะคะอืทำ 1 ปีน่ะ 1 ครั้ง
อืทำอะไรคะครูเอ๋อ๋อทำบุญบ้านอ้าทำบุญ
บ้านเพราะว่าเราอยู่บ้านใช่มั้ยครูต้อม
อ่ะครูเออันค่ะเราอยู่บ้านปึ๊บอครูเอ๋วาด
บ้านนะ
คะอุ้ยไม่ใช่วัดบ้านครูครูเอ๋วาดบัครูเอ๋
วาดวัดบนๆๆโอเคโอเคอ่ะๆเหมือนมั้ยเหมือน
มยอ่ะครูเอ๋วาดง่ายๆไม่เหมือนเพราะว่ามี
ข้างบนเคะจั่วเนี่ยค่ะอืโอเคโอเคเหมือน
กาแรอ่ะโอ้ยเอ่า
โอเคครูเอกจะวาดบ้านเป็นวัดตลอดนะคะนัก
เรียนอ่ะบ้านช
วัดชอบแต่ไม่ได้ไปทีนี้ที่บ้านก็จะมีเป็น
แบบนี้เป็นเล็ก
ๆ
อืบ้านเล็กๆหรอคะใช่มีเสาเดียวอันนี้สวยๆ
เหมือนวัด
[เพลง]
ออ
เนาะเป็นแบบนี้เนาะ
ค่ะแล้วบางบ้านก็จะมีเล็กๆตรงนี้ด้วยครู
ต้อม
ค่ะมี 2 เลยมี 2
อืนะคะก็คือที่บ้านเนี่ยบ้านที่บ้านที่
บ้านคนไทยอ่ะนะคะเขาก็เชื่อว่าอ่าตนี้
บ้านที่บ้านใช่มั้ยคะบ้านก็จะมีมีมีผี
อู้
[เพลง]
ผีผีบ้านผีเรือน
อ่าผีที่ 1 นะคะผีบ้านผีเรือนอยู่ที่บ้าน
นะคะที่ 2 อันนี้เป็นเทวดา
นะเทวดา
ออยู่ที่ศานี้นะคะเป็นเทวดาข้างบนหรือ
เป็นเทพแล้วแต่ว่าเขาจะมีอะไรเชิญเชิญใคร
มาอยู่ที่นี่เราเรียกว่าเทดาหรอคะครูเอ๋
อยู่ที่ศาลใช่เรียกว่าศาลอะไรนะคะครูต้อม
ศาลพระภูมิอ่าศาลพระภูมิแล้วก็มีผีอีกตรง
นี้ที่นี่อึบ
อู้บ้านครูเอ๋มี 2 สารอืมผีเอ่อที่นี่
เรียกว่าอะไรนะคะครูต้อมสารเจ้าที่ปิงปอง
เก่งมากอืบางทีก็เรียกศาลตายายนะูเอ๋อ๋อ
ใช่ถ้าตายายก็คือเจ้าที่นั่นแหละแต่ว่ามี
มีคุณตากับคุณยายสามีภรรยาเหมือนกันแต่
บ้านครูเอ๋อ่ะไม่ใช่ตายายอืเป็นปู่อ่อมี 3
มี 3  3  3  3 อะไรอ่ะ 3 องค์ 3 องค์ 3
คน 3 ตน 3 ตน 3 ท่าน 3 ท่านน่ะเเรียกว่า 3
ท่านมีปู่ 3 ปู่เป็นผู้ชายหมดเลยนะคะเป็น
ผู้ชายหมดก็ก็จะอยู่ที่ศาลศาลที่นี่นะคะ
แล้วก็อ่าที่นี่ก็จะเป็นพระภูมิแล้วก็ที่
บ้านก็จะมีผีบ้านผีเรือนทีนี้เนี่ยนัก
เรียนก็จะสงสัยอ้าทำไมมีผีที่บ้านแล้วผี
เป็นใครต้องบอกนักเรียนว่าสมัยโบราณเนาะ
บ้านเนี่ยเราทำจากไม้อือ่าในไม้บนต้นไม้
เองเราก็อาจจะเชื่อว่ามีวิญญาณอยู่ในต้น
ไม้นะคะอ๋อแต่วิญญาณวิญญาณคืออะไร
[เพลง]
อืแล้วลค่ะเออก็จะเป็นเอ่อหรือพิธีเรียก
ผีบ้านผีเรือนยังไงเอ๋ตรงเนี้ยเอ๋ก็ไม่
แน่ใจแต่ตั้งแต่เด็กเนี่ยเขาก็บอกว่าที่
บ้านมีผีบ้านผีเรือนที่ศาลพระภูมิมีพระ
ภูมิเป็นเทวดานะคะแล้วก็ที่ศาลศาลเล็กๆ
เนี่ยก็มีเจ้าที่เจ้าที่นี่ก็คือเจ้าของ
ของที่ดินที่ดินที่นี่อ่าที่ดินเรามาปลูก
บ้านเราอาจจะตัดต้นไม้ที่อยู่ที่นี่ก็
ต้องทำบ้านให้เจ้าที่นะคะแล้วก็เชิญพระ
ภูมิมาทำไมต้องมีเยอะเพราะว่าคนไทยเรา
กลัวผี
อุ๊ยคนไทยเรากลัวผีนะคะเมื่อคนไทยกลัวผี
เดี๋ยวนะขอโทษคุค่ะขอปิดโทรศัพท์ครูต้อม
ก็กลัวผีนะครูเออ๋อืกลัวผีใช่มยใช่แล้ว
เวลาที่เดินผ่านศาพระภูมิก็จะต้องสาธุค่ะ
สาธุค่ะเดี๋ยวครูต้อมกลัวศาลพระภูมิหรือ
ว่ากลัวผีข้าง
นอกกลัวผีข้างนอกค่ะก็ต้องไหว้ศาลพระภูมิ
ไหว้ศาลเจ้าที่ให้มาดูแลครูต้อมอย่าให้ผี
มาหลอกอ่าใช่ถ้าเราไหว้สาลพระภูมิบ่อยๆ
ใช่มั้ยคะพระภูมิแข็งแรงเวลาเรากลับเข้า
บ้านบอาจจะมีผีเดินตามมาพระภูมิอ่อเจ้า
ที่แล้วก็ผีบ้านผีเรือนนะคะอผีบ้านผี
เรือนเจ้าพระภูมิแล้วก็เจ้าหนที่ก็จะอ้า
อย่ามานะ
ออเราก็เข้าบ้านนอนอย่างสบายๆผีข้างนอกก็
เข้าบ้านเราไม่ได้นะใช่ฉะนั้นน่ะเราต้อง
ไหว้ต้องทำความสะอาดแต่คนคนไทยคนไทยเวลา
ทำบ้านใหม่สมมุติทำบ้านทำบ้านเสร็จครั้ง
แรกเลยเนี่ยเค้าก็จะมีสตั้งศาลพระภูมิมี
ศาลเจ้าที่แล้วเก็จะทำบุญที่บ้านไม่ไปที่
วัดครูต้อมค่ะแต่ที่ครูเอ๋พูดเมื่อกี้บอก
ว่าเอ่อ 1 ปี 1 ครั้งเนี่ยเ่อคนไทยบางคน
เขาก็ไม่ใช่แค่ครั้งแรกครั้งเดียวเค้าทำ
ทุกปีอือืพอทำบ้านนเยบ้านเนี้ยพิ่งเสร็จ
บ้านเสร็จแล้วก็ย้ายเข้ามาอันเนี้ยทำบุญ
ก่อนเขาจะทำบุญก่อน 1 ครั้งใช่มั้ยคะค่ะ
ปีหน้าทำอีกปีหน้าทำอีกบ้านเอ๋ทำครั้ง
เดียวนะฮะอืบ้านครูต้อมล่ะบ้านครูต้อมตอน
ที่ครูต้อมเด็กๆอ่ะค่ะก็ทำบุญเอ่อทุกปีปี
ละครั้งแต่พอโตขึ้นแล้วย้ายบ้านมาอยู่
บ้านเล็กๆก็ไม่ได้ทำค่ะอืบ้านครูเอ๋ก็ทำ
ครั้งเดียวแต่ว่าถ้าอยากทำก็ก็ทำอ่าแต่
แต่เป็นไทยจีนก็ไม่ค่อยได้ทำเพราะว่าไหว้
มีไหว้ที่บ้าน 1 ปี 1  2  3 มีไหว้เยอะๆ
อ๋อไหว้เจ้าตรุษจีนใช่มีไหว้ตุดจีนไหว้า
จีนไหว้ไม่รู้ไหว้อะไรไหว้เยอะๆแล้วจรง
เม้งงี้อืเชงเม้งไปที่ที่วัดเอออ๋อแต่ว่า
ถ้าเกิดมาไหว้ทำบุญบ้านอีกก็จะเยอะมากนะ
คะออค่ะเพราะเพราะว่าไหว้ไหว้ไหว้ 1 ปี
เอ้ย 1 ปีน่ะ 52 ครั้งอยู่แล้ววันพระเรา
ต้องไหว้อ๋อเวันพระเนี่ยต้องว่าต้องมี
อาหารมีน้ำมีดอกไม้ที่นี่ตจีนนะคะถ้าปี
ใหม่นักเรียนวันที่ 1 มกราคมค่ะอันเนี้ย
ปีใหม่เราก็ไหว้แล้วก็ประมาณประมาณ
กุมภาพันธ์ก็เป็นตรุษจีนนะคะอ่าปีใหม่คน
จีนอืเราก็ไหว้นะคะอือ่ะทีนี้วันนี้เราจะ
พูดถึงทำบุญขึ้นบ้านใหม่อ้าหรือทำบุญบ้าน
ค่ะนะถ้ามีบ้านใหม่ก็ทำบุญขึ้นบ้านใหม่ 1
ครั้งบางคนทำทุกปีก็พูดทำบุญบ้านนะนะคะ
ค่ะถ้านักเรียนมีเพื่อนคนไทยก็อาจจะเอ๊ะ
เพื่อนบอกมาๆมางานทำบุญบ้าน
อืทำบุญบ้านคืออะไรูเออ๋ทำบุญบ้านเนี่ย
อันดับแรกเลยเจ้าของบ้านต้องไปเชิญพระ
ก่อนครูต้องอแล้วสาธุค่ะูเอ๋วาดเองนะ
เนี่ยันนี้บอกเกเก่งอยู่อย่างเงี้ยอหายใจ
หรือเปล่าคะหายใจไม่ได้หายใจลืมคือวรูเกง
ก็ดูแล้วก็วาดครูเอ๋นิมนต์พระมาสาธุคใช่
เวลาเราไปเชิญพระมาเราพูดว่าอะไรนะครู
ต้อมพูดเมื่อกี้นี้นิมนต์ค่ะอ่าก็ต้องไป
นิมนต์พระที่ไหนคะที่วัดค่ะที่วัดนะคะไป
ที่วัดแล้วเราก็ไปนิมนต์พระบอกพระวันไหน
ค่ะทำบุญบ้านพระกี่รูปคะครูต้อมทำบุญบ้าน
พระ 9 รูปอ่าพระเนี่ย 9 นะคะค่ะออแต่ถ้า
ที่บ้านมีเงินนิดหน่อย 1 รูป
อ้าไม่ได้ 5 รูปได้มย 3 รูปได้มยได้ๆ 3
รูป 3 รูป 5 รูป 7 รูปอืได้นะคะแต่ถ้าไม่
มีพระจริงๆคือพระติดธุระก็ 1 รูปก็ได้แต่
ส่วนมากก็คือ 3  3 ไม่ใช่ส่วนมากส่วน 1  3
นิดหน่อย 5  5 ส่วนใหญ่จะ 5  5 นะคะ
5  7  9 อ่าส่วนใหญ่ก็คือ 80% เนาะ
ประมาณ 80% เเราพูดว่าส่วนใหญ่นะคะคืออาจ
จะ 20% พระ 3 รูป 1 รูปแต่ส่วนใหญ่ก็คือ 5
รูป 7 รูป 9 รูปคือดีที่สุดสุดอือืนะฮะ
ต้องเชิญพระมาที่บ้านนะ 9 รูปแล้วก็ต้อง
เตรียมของด้วยนะครูต้อมโูครูต้อมนี่ชอบ
มากเลยค่ะเนี่ยต้องเเตรียมเตรียมตัวนี้
ของพระอ๋ออเรียกสวยจังู้
เอวาสีสวยชอบอ่ะค่ะสดใสดีอเรียกว่าอะไรคะ
อันนี้เาเรียกว่าออานะอ่ะอาสนะแต่ว่าเรา
ต้องซื้อเองมั้ยอ่ะไม่ต้องค่ะเราไปขอยืม
จากที่วัดอ๋อก็ยืมที่วัดเอามาคือถ้าเชิญ
พระเอ่อนิมนต์พระค่ะนิมนต์พระ้ารูปแล้วก็
ยืมยืมออาสนะก้าที่ใช่มั้ยคะอาสนะนี่เอา
ไว้ทำอะไรคะครูต้อมเอาไว้ให้พระนั่งค่ะออ
เป็นเหมือนเก้าอี้ของพระเหมือนเป็น
เก้าอี้ของพระโอเคอ่ะพระมาแล้วก็นั่ง
อ่าครูเอกกอปี้ก่อนนะคะนัก
เรียนปึ๊บ
อโอเคพลักกันนมาแล้วมา 2
ะ 3 อ่า
อื 4 อ่ะเอาพอมั้ยอ่ะ 5 แล้วกันนะ
มาค่ะเดี๋ยวจะเสียเวลาพูดอ้าโอเคมาค่ะก็
จะมีพระออันนี้จะเป็นเณรไปนะคะตัวเล็กๆเอ
ๆรูปร่างเล็กๆอ่ะโอเคเราก็จะมีอาสนะพระจะ
ต้องนั่งบนอาสนะ
เนาะค่ะนั่งที่อาสนะนะคะแล้วก็มีมีอีกอัน
นี้นะ
คะ
มีโอนี่เอาของที่บ้านออกมาได้ค่ะหรือว่า
ขอยืมที่วัดก็ได้อ๋อเอ๊ยแต่ถ้าเกิดเรามี
พระอยู่ที่บ้านใช้พระอธิบาเรายืมแต่โต๊ะ
หมู่บูชาอันนี้เรียกว่าโต๊ะหมู่บูชานะครู
เอเนอ่าใช่ตัวนี้โต๊ะหมู่บูชาแต่ว่าแต่
ว่าเอ่อองค์พระองค์พระพุทธรูปอันเนี้ยของ
เราได้ใช่มั้ยคะค่ะอืแต่ถ้าที่บ้านมี
อืบ้านมีก็มีมีชุดนี้ก็ยกออกมาเลยใช่มค่ะ
แต่แต่ถ้าไม่มีก็ยืมของของวัดมานะคะค่ะ
แล้วเในโต๊ะหมูบูชาตัวนี้มีอะไรคะครูต้อม
แจกันค่ะครูเอ๋แจกันดอกไม้แจกันดอกไม้
แล้วตัวนี้ล่ะคะกระถางธูปกระถางธูปนะคะ
อ่าเอ่อต้มหมู่บูชานี่
อ่าจำเป็นต้องมีเยอะขนาดนี้ั้คะครูต้อม
หรือว่ามี 1 ก็ได้ไม่ต้องก็ได้ค่ะครูเอ๋
มีพระ 1 องค์ก็ได้ค่ะอ้อมีพระพระพระ
พุทธรูปนะคะองค์นี้
อ 1 องค์อง์ได้โอเคแล้วค่ะอ่ะเราพูดถึง
ของที่เตรียมกันเนาะค่ะอ่ะแล้วก็มีชุดนี้
โออันนี้เรียกว่าอะไรนะอ่าเรียกว่าชุด
สังฆทานชุดสังฆทาน
เอ่อบางคนก็มีเท่านี้ก็ได้นะคะบางคน้า
อะไรนะครูเอ๋เนี่ย้าไตรผ้าไตรนะคะผ้าไตร
จีวรของพระนะคะบางทีก็มีคือชุดเยก็จะแพง
นิดนึงถ้าเป็นคนที่แบบรายได้น้อยๆแต่อยาก
ทำบุญบ้านอาจจะไม่มีชุดนี้ก็จะมีชุดนี้
แทนนะคะหรือบางคนก็มีครบหมดเลยก็ได้อือื
เพราะว่าถ้า 9 ชุดโอบางคนก็ไม่ไหวแต่อยาก
ทำบุญบ้านก็มีมีชุดสังฆทานชุดนี้ก็ได้นะ
คะค่ะหรือบางทีไม่มีก็ได้นะเพราเพราะว่า
เราต้องทำอาหารแล้วก็ค่ะพระค่ะไปคุยกับ
พระพระบอกว่าอาหารที่ถวายพระก็เรียกว่า
สังฆทานอือ่าไม่ต้องมีชุดนี้ก็ได้ค่ะผู้
เอ๋คะแล้วในชุดสังฆทานต้องมีอะไรบ้างคะ
อ่าในชุดสังฆทานก็มียาเนาะอันเนี่ยมียา
เวลาพระปวดหัวใช่กินยามียามีเดี๋ยวนี้เอ๋
เห็นเใส่อะไรนะผงซักฟอกอืสำหรับซักผ้านะ
คะสำหรับซักผ้าใส่พี่กหนวดอ่าที่โกหนวด
รองเท้ากนผมรองเท้า
องเท้าของพระนะคะอของจำเป็นน่ะค่ะที่พระ
จะใช้แต่แต่จริงๆครูเอกก็ยังสงสัยผงซัก
ฟอกก็ต้องเลือกนะหอมๆเไม่ได้นะหรอแต่ว่า
ผงซักฟอกทุกอันก็คือหอมหมดเลยอ่ะเออหอม
แบบเป็นกลิ่นดอกไม้กลิ่นอะไรอย่างเงี้ย
แต่เป็นผงซักฟอกกลิ่นแบบเมื่อก่อนน่ะโอเค
ค่ะนะคะโอยา
ดมยาดมอ่ะที่ครูต้อมมีอ่ะอ้าได้มั้ยครู
เออ๋ได้ๆยาหม่องเวลาพระไม่ไม่สว่าปวดหัว
อย่างงี้ใช่นะคะคือจริงๆถ้าเราไม่รู้เรา
ก็ไปที่ร้านแล้วก็บอกว่าขอจัดชุดสังฆทาน 1
ชุดแต่ถ้าเรารู้เราก็ไปเลือกซื้อเองนะคะ
ยาแก้ปวดหัวอ่าแปรงสีฟันอ่าแก้ปวดท้องแก้
ปวดท้องได้นะคะค่ะอแล้วก็ต้องมีตัวนี้ค่ะ
ครูต้อมอะไรอ๋ออันนี้อะไรคะเนี่ยสายสินโห
ตอนแรกครูต้องคิดว่าเป็นลูกกอล์ฟซะอีกไม่
ใช่สายสินคือหลังจากที่้าสวดมนต์ใช่มั้ย
ก็จะต้องมีสายสินน่ะพันรอบบ้านเลยนัก
เรียนออเป็นโอบ้านอันนี้นะคะบ้านนะคะเค้า
ก็จะเอาสายสบ้านปืบอ่ะครูเอ๋วาดบ้านอย่าง
นี้สายสินนะครูเอชอบมากเลยบอกพระพันธุ์
เยอะๆ
สาย
อืรอบๆบ้านไปศาลพระภูมิไปทุกที่ค่ะคือ
บ้านนี้ผีเข้าไม่ได้แล้ว
นะครูเอ๋นี่ครูต้อมจะแอบเล่าให้ฟังนิดนึง
ที่คอนโดตอนนี้ครูต้อมอยู่คอนโดใช่มั้ยคะ
ที่คอนโดก็มีทำบุญบ้านเนี่ยทำบุญที่คอนโด
ทุกปีเหมเหมือนกันแล้วเคก็พันสายสินแบบ
เนี้ยรอบคอนโดเลยครูเออ๋ไปถึงป้อมยามไป
ถึงนู่นๆกว้างมากรอบต้นไม้เลยค่ะอือืแล้ว
มี 3 ตึกอ่ะกครูเออ๋อ๋อแล้วทำบุนเดียวโอ
ผันยาวเลยพันรอบรั้ว 3 ตึกเลยค่ะงั้นก็
ต้องซื้อสายสินเค้าเรียกอะไรนะก้อนใช่มั้
ก้อนใหญ่คูะ 2 ม้วนใหญเอม้วนๆๆไม่ใช่ก้อน
ใหญม้วน 3 ม้วนอออแต่แต่เวลาเราเห็นแล้ว
เรารู้สึกสบายใจนะ
ใช่ผีจะไม่มาใช่หรืออะไรที่ไม่ดีอ่ะจะไม่
เข้ามาที่บ้านหรือเข้ามาที่คอนโดนะคะใช่
ค่ะแล้วก็อันนึงที่ครูเอ๋ชอบก็คืออัน
นี้เอ่อเขาจะมีขันแล้วก็มีน้ำออแล้วก็มี
เทียนนะคะมีมีเทียนแบบนี้แล้วก็มีธูปอ่า
พระจะสวดมนต์แล้วก็ทำน้ำเรียกว่าน้ำมนต์
นะคะอูอันนี้ก็ดีค่ะครูต้มก็ชอบอีกค่ะอ
น้ำมนต์น่ะพอน้ำมนต์ปั๊บเจะมีตัวนี้ด้วย
นะตัวนี้ตัว
นี้เป็นไม้สำหรับจุ่มในน้ำมนต์แล้วก็ซับ
แล้วก็จะไหว้พระสาธุพระก็จะพมน้ำบนชุดๆๆๆ
ๆเหก็ฝนตกค่ะโอโชคดีโชคดีนะคครูต้อมนะคะ
แว่นเนี่ยนะคะเปียกหมดเลยค่ะครูเอ๋แต่
สบายใจใช่มั้ยไม่สบายใจต้องมาเช็ดแว่นอีก
ค่ะโอ๊ยเป็นน้ำมนต์ค่ะสาธุโชคดีครูเอ๋แต่
ครูต้อมชอบขันน้ำมนต์ทำไมคะสวยตอูเวลาเอา
เทียนค่ะหยดติ๊งๆงๆลงไปในขันนะครูเอ๋ครู
ต้อมก็จะไปมองดูในขันนั่นน่ะค่ะขันน้ำ
มนต์น่ะค่ะมองทำไมมองว่ามันเป็นขึ้นเป็น
ตัวเลขกูต้องกูต้องเล
2 ทำบุญคิดลอตเตอรี่นะกูต้องเผื่อจะโชค
ดีอันนี้เรื่องจริงนะคะนักเรียนพอทำใช่
งานบุญเนี่ยทุกคนจะดูดูนี่เลยค่ะเลขอะไร
เทียนเต่อกันเป็นเลขอะไรกูตเห็นเป็นเลข
อะไรคะเนี่ยเห็นเป็นเลข
อืเลข
3 เลข 5  5 มีมั้ยคะอ๋ออันนี้ 5 อุ๊ยเลข
2 ครูเอ๋อันนี้ 2 โอ้โหออโอเคคิดได้ต้อง
จะไปซื้อล็อตเตอรรี่
คืออันนี้คือของที่ต้องเตรียมนะพะพระจะ
ซัดซัดน้ำมนต์ให้เรารดน้ำมนต์นะคะรดน้ำ
มนต์นะคะอันนี้ที่เรียกว่าเป็นไฮไลท์ของ
งานทำบุญบ้านเลยนะครูเอ๋อ๋อต้องรอตอนนี้
ใช่มั้ยใช่รอน้ำมนต์เลขอะไรใช่ค่ะว่าเลข
อะไรนะคะอืใช่แล้วมีอะไรอีกมั้ยคะอ๋อคือ
จะบอกว่าถ้าเกิดตัวเนี้ยเ่อไม้ที่เป็นไม้
ซัดน้ำมนต์นะคะตอนครูไเด็กๆอ่ะเอ่อที่
บ้านไม่มีตัวนี้นะเไม่มีทำขายต้องทำเอง
สมัยก่อนไม่มีขายก็จะทำเองที่บ้านจะใช้
อันนี้ม้ายมะยมแทนอ๋อเนี่ยลูกมะยมต้นมะยม
เขาจะเอาตรงเนี้ยค่ะก้านมะยมแล้วก็เอามา
ผูกรวมกันอืคือหรือเอาต้นไม้ที่มีชื่อดีๆ
อ่ะค่ะเอามาผูกรวมกันแล้วก็จุ่มในน้ำมนต์
แล้วก็ซัดน้ำมนต์อ่าก็จะมะยมชื่อดีใช่มย
นิค่ะนิยมแปลว่าคนชอบมากๆนะฮะอืงั้นน่ะก็
ใช้ใช้อ่าไม้มะยมได้ถ้าไม่มีตัวนี้นะคะอื
มีอะไรอีกอ๋อมีอันนี้ดอกไม้
อืแต่ดอกดอกบัวอ่าดอกบัวถวายพระไหว้พระ
แล้วก็ต้องมีเดี๋ยวนะกุ
สีเหลืองมี
เทียน
อืมีเทียนด้วยนะ
คะมีธูปธูปสีน้ำตาลเนาะอืมีธูปนะ
คะธูปรูปถวายพระเนี่ยถวายพระ 1  1 รูปก็
ต้อง 3 ดอกเนาะค่ะไหว้พระพุทธพระพุทธก็
องค์
นี้พระพุทธก็ 3 ดอกเหมือนกันอืแต่บางคน
เทียนไหว้พระพุทธเป็นเทียน 2 เทียนคู่ก็
มีอ
คแล้วก็มีนี่มีมีของกิน
อู
เออชุดนี้เรากินไม่ได้นะคะครูครูต้อมชุด
นี้จะของพระ
พุทธชุดนี้จะเป็นเป็นของพระนี่ค่ะพระพุทธ
นะคะอ่าเราเรียกพระพุทธก็คือพระพุทธรูป
พระพุทธเจ้านะคะออืก็จะมีชุดเอ่อจริงๆ
เป็นชุดสวยๆแบบนี้ก็ได้หรือแบบไหนก็ได้
เป็นถ้วยเล็กๆแล้วก็มีอาหารนะคะมีข้าวมี
น้ำน้มีขนมก็จะไหว้พระพุทธก่อนนะคะอแล้ว
ก็ค่อยค่อยไปไหว้พระสงฆ์อืนะทีนี้เนี่ย
ไฮไลท์ครูต้อมบอกไฮไลท์ของครูต้อมคือตรง
นี้ใช่มยใช่ค่ะน้ำมนต์นะคะอ่าน้ำมนต์อ่า
ส่วนไฮไลท์ของครูเอ๋ก็คืออันนี้ค่ะอาหาร
ฮู้น่ากินมากน่ากินมากอันนี้ของอันนี้
อาหารรุ่นพรุ่นพี่ครูเอ๋ทำอ๋ออันนี้คือ
เวลาพระมาถึงสวดมนต์เสร็จแล้วเราก็จะถวาย
อาหารใช่มั้ยครูเอ๋ใช่ๆถวายอาหารและอาหาร
ที่ที่จะต้องมี
เนี่ยไม่รู้นะปัจจุบันน่ะอาหารอะไรก็ได้
แต่ถ้าเป็นสมัยก่อนน่ะครูเอ๋จำได้ว่าทำ
บุญบ้านเนี่ยต้องมีขนมจีนน้ำยาหรือขนมจีน
แกงเขียวหวานอือันนี้แกงเขียวหวานแล้วก็
ขนมจีนตัวนี้ขนมจีนนักเรียนอันนี้แกง
เขียวหวานค่ะเพราะอะไรอ่ะคะครูเอ๋อะไรนะ
คะออเพราะอะไรถึงต้องมีมีเส้นไงคะเป็น
เส้นยาวๆอ่าอ๋ออายุยืนโอูเออู๋เออ๋ถ้า
งั้นครูต้อมเคยเห็นนะตอนเนี้ยบางบ้านน่ะ
ไม่ใช้ขนมจีจีนใช่มั้ยคะแต่ว่าใช้เส้น
บะหมี่อ๋อก็มีนะคะครูเอ๋แบนั้นเเเป็นไทย
จีนใช่เป็นบะหมี่เป็ดอะไรอย่างเงี้ยใช่ๆ
คือต้องมีเส้นน่ะมีอาหารเป็นเส้นแต่ถ้า
เป็นไทยจีนเขาจะมีเส้นบะหมี่แบบเส้นเดียว
ยาวๆเลยอ่ะูต้อง
ยแต่ถ้าเป็นเป็นคนไทยก็เป็นขนมจีนแกง
เขียวหวานขนมจีนน้ำยาก็ได้แต่ครูเอขนมจีน
แกงเขียวหวานคือบ้านครูเอ๋น่ะจะไม่ทำหิว
เลยไม่ทำอาหารที่มีกะทิแบบนี้ฉะนั้นเี่
เวลางานบุญเ่ะเขาจะมีอาหารที่มีกะทิคือ
แกงเขียวหวานแล้วก็ขนมจีนครูเอ๋ก็เลยชอบ
เอ้ยได้กินอืเพะบ้านเคเไทยจีนจะทำอาหาร
แบบไทยจีนนะคะค่ะแล้วก็นอกจากอาหารคือมี
อะไรก็ได้นะคะนักเรียนนะคะแต่ว่าอ่าต้อง
มีอันนี้อืแต่ปัจจุบันไม่มีใช่มั้ยบะหมี่
เป็ดแทนมีก็ยังมีอยู่ค่ะแต่บางคนก็แบบ
เบื่ออ๋อเบื่อขนมจีนเบื่อขนมจีนก็จะเอา
เป็นบะหมี่อืคุณต้อมเคยทำบุญที่
บริษัทก็สั่ง
ฮัลโหลสั่งบะหมี่อืเดลิเวอรี่มาส่งที่ทำ
งานอ่ะค่ะค่ะอืก็จะเป็นบาหมี่เป็ด MK
อย่างเงี้ยเอามาถวายพระก็ง่ายๆดีกูเคือ
เค้ามีที่นะหลายๆร้านอาหารหลายๆที่เา้าก็
รับจัดอาหารสำหรับทำบุญบ้านแต่ว่าอันอัน
นี้เราเรานำเสนอแบบโบร่ำโบราณค่ะแล้วก็จะ
มีขนมนี่ๆขนมที่ต้องมีค่ะต้องบอกนักเรียน
นะคะอ่าขนมที่ต้องมีแบบเมื่อก่อนอคือขนม
อะไรก็ได้แต่ต้องมีมีอันนี้ค่ะถ้วยฟู
อืถ้วยฟูแปลว่าอยู่แล้วเฟื่องฟูธุรกิดีนะ
คะคนอยู่บ้านนี้เอ่อทำงานก็มีตำแหน่งสูงๆ
ๆงขึ้นจากจากสตาฟก็เป็นอะไรนะเนเจอร์ใช่
ผู้จัดการเป็นผู้จัดการเป็นหัวหน้านะคะ
ใช่แล้วก็มีขนมหวานพวกนี้ขนมหวานไทยๆมี
ฝอย
ทองทองหยอดทองหยิบเม็ด
ขนก็คือหวานครอบครัวมีความสุขหวาน
โอ้อืรักกันโอ้พอพระกิน
แล้วเรียบร้อยแล้วครูเอ๋กินมั้ยคะกินค่ะ
ชอบค่ะครูเอ๋ชอบขนมหวานไทยอืแต่ขนมเค้ก
ขนมอะไรเนี่ยครูเอ๋กินหวานไม่ไม่ได้ไม่
หวานโอเคแต่ถ้าขนมหวานไทยเนี่ยโอ๊ยอร่อย
อ๋อต้องกินมั้ยกินค่ะครูต้อมชอบขนมชั้น
ชอบคเนี่ยอันเนี้ยขนมชั้นน่ะครูเอ๋สีชมพู
อ่ะอันนี้ขนมชั้นอค่าแล้วครูต้อมชอบเม็ด
ขนุนอือันนี้เม็ดขนุนนะคะอืทองหยิบททอง
หยิบ
ทองหยอดทองหยอดป๋อยทองูต้อมชอบหมดเลย
นี่ชอบเม็ดขนุนอ่ะเม็ดขนุนอันเดียวไม่
เป็นไรชอบหมดก็
ได้เออทองทองหยอดอ่ะมันเรียกพูดยากนะครู
เอ๋ทองหยิบทองหยอดฝอยทองพูดยากเนาะค่ะใช่
จำไม่ได้ครูเอ๋ชอบที่สุดก็คืออัน
นี้อะไรคะอ่าออทองหยอดใช่ๆๆอ่ะสีเขียว
แล้วกันทองหยอดทองหยอดมากมันหวานมากครู
เออ๋หวานเจี๊ยบขวานกินได้เนตอนนี้้องน้อย
ๆ
อืคือทำไมต้องมีเอ่อขนมชั้นทำไมต้องมีนะ
คะนักเรียนคือขนมชั้นเนี่ยปกติเนี่ยเขาจะ
ใช้ในงานเวลาที่ทำงานแล้วตำแหน่งงาน
สมมุติว่าครูเอ๋เป็นครูแล้ววันนึงได้
เลื่อนเป็นหัวหน้าครูนะคะก็จะมีทำบุญที่
บ้านฉลองตำแหน่งงานเขาก็จะ
ใช้ขนมชั้น 9 ชั้น
อื 9 ชั้น 9 ชั้นอันนี้กี่ชั้นนะ 1  2  2
3  4  5  6 เออกี่ชั้นอ่ะ 1  2  3  4 ะ
อันนี้กี่ชั้นไม่รู้เครูเอ๋ก็นับไม่ได้นะ
ต้องขยายใหญ่ๆก่อนอืต้องขยายใหญ่ๆครูเอ๋
จะหมดเวลาแล้วนะขยายนับขนมชั้นอีก 1  2  3
4  5  6  7  8  9  10 อุ๊ยทำไม 12 อู
เยอะอ่ะเเไม่ได้คิดเรื่อง 9 ชั้นแล้วมั้ง
ครูเอ๋เออไม่ไม่ใชอันนี้อันนี้อันนี้น่า
จะไม่ได้เกี่ยวกับงานงานงานฉลองตำแหน่ง
แต่ถ้างานฉลองตำแหน่งต้อง 9 ชั้นนะคะอื
้าวหน้าภาษาไทย้าหน้าเหมือนนักเรียนฟัง
ภาษาไทยฟังครั้งที่ 1 ไม่เข้าใจอ่าฟัง 2
3 ฟังครั้งที่ 100 เข้าใจฟังครั้งที่ 300
พูดได้ก้าวหน้านะก้าวไปข้างหน้าก้าวไป
ข้างหน้าอุ๊ยจะหมดๆเวลาแล้วใช่มั้ยนัก
เรียนหมดแล้วครูเอ๋ 50 แล้วออคือวันนี้
ครูเอ๋ก็ให้นักเรียนเห็นว่าคนไทย
ทำทำบุญบ้านเนี่ยเค้ามีอะไรบ้างถ้านัก
เรียนไปแล้วนักเรียนเห็นจะได้รู้ว่าอัน
นี้คืออะไรมีไว้ทำไมนะคะอืแต่พระสวดหรือ
อะไรเรายังไม่ไม่บอกเนาะแล้วเวลาวันไหน
ที่จะทำบุญบ้านวันที่มีเวลา
อืที่คุณสะดวกสบายนะคะก็ทำวันนั้นนะคะ
โอเคค่ะอหมดเวลาแล้วจริงๆงานทำบุญบ้านมี
อะไรอีกเยอะไวนะู้เยอะมากเลยไปฟังระดับ
intermediate  Advance อ่าเราจะพูดได้
เยอะกว่านี้โอเคโอเคแล้วนะคะคลิปสุดท้าย
ของครูเอกกับครูต้อมอู้
หกดไลก์เยอะๆกดไลก์เยอะๆนะคะเดี๋ยวเอาไว้
เรามามีเววลามานะครูเอ๋เราก็มาคุยกันอีก
ในช่องของครูเอ๋นี่แหละสนุกๆคุยกันได้ค่ะ
โอเคค่ะบ๊ายบายค่ะบ๊ายบายนะคะนักเรียน
ขอบคุณนะคะขอบคุณค่ะครูเอ๋บ๊าย
[เพลง]
บาย